hello everyone and welcome back to the
world fish random championship it's
Magnus Carlsen versus Fabiana Caruana
now we are back in the semi-finals and
well the the four classical games are
over
Magnus won two games Fabi won one game
and won one of the games were drawn now
this is the first game of the rapid
section rapid section is 15 minutes each
but there is an increment so there is a
two second increment starting from move
one that being said let's check out the
game Magnus would the white pieces opens
with c4 and no it is not the English
opening since well it's a world Fisher
random championship we have g6 by Fabi
and now III preparing to grab the
central with d4 with b6 opening up the
other the light square bishop as well as
you can see now Fabi some using some
hyper-modern opening techniques with
Quinta a2 and Knight to d6 now by Fabi
the for Magnus grabs the center and
Queen to h6 now I don't think the the
principle bring your queen out too early
goes for official random but you know
the the theory is still to be created
with castles by by far by cross and
castles by Fabi as well and Knight to c3
now with six and now b3 opening up the
dark square bishop as well we have
Knight to c6 and now d5 and grabbing
more space in the center
forcing Fabi to take action we have a
key sorry
ich after Sundy 5c captures on d5 and a
knight to e7 g3 opening up the light
square bishop and now rook dt 8 as the
e-file is now semi open so after the
knight moves it will be a very nice file
for the rook with Queen to b3 and now a5
we have Knight wanted Knight 1 to e 2
and Bishop the b7 so now the night here
guards the bishop as well and if needed
you could you could switch the rook over
to a8 if you need to put a 4 there or
use ideas like that Bishop to b2 and now
comes f5 bye-bye Fabi the ship back to
a3 now it's a very nice diagonal for the
Bishop and Bishop to e5
if
Bishop captures and leases then you can
recapture with the bishop you don't have
to ruin your pawn structure but here is
where Magnus gets the idea first night
to the d4 and excellent outpost for the
night if you want to get rid of it you
will either have to give up your Bishop
air or or think of some other ideas how
to get rid of it so Queen the g7 first
and now f4 it's a it's a change in the
position change in the pawn structure
but Magnus does it with the idea that he
wants to capture here so beshrew back to
f6 and then out Bishop captures nb6 with
C captures on d6 and now with the with
the depot pawns doubled up like this
this LightSquared bishop will not be and
not become very useful we have Brooke
ft-1 with ideas of pushing efore at some
point and now rook the c8 the C file is
now open so you want to put your rooks
there Knight see the b5 going after the
d6 pawn and now push up the a sec
spinning the night as the Queen is still
on d3 Queen back to b1 and now comes
Bishop captures on d4 you have to start
trading otherwise you're gonna lose the
d6 pawn so bunch of characters on d4 we
have Knight captures on d4 and now rook
the c5 going after White's d5 pawn
Magnus plays B for the rookies under
attack so it captures on b4 Queen
captures on before and now Bishop to c4
again with a double attack a triple
attack now towards the d5 pawn Magnus
captures and b6 and now comes Queen to
f6 he doesn't want to give up the d6
pawn you could play Knight captures here
then you lose this pawn so first Queen
to f6 and now Queen to b7 attacking the
d7 pawn and here Magnus says okay if you
want you can grab my eight two point I'm
gonna grab this pawn attack threatened
Knight the e6 so what what will you play
here it's very hard to find a move that
that prevents such ideas for example you
have to get rid of the d5 pawn at some
point if you do it now nice the e6 will
Wilfork both the roof so it's not easy
to find a move that
that you know helps you with that you
could move the rook rook a5 but still
nice to e6 is a very ugly move to face
so here Bobby doesn't like Bishop
characters followed by Queen captures
and e7 instead he plays rook to b8 he
defends the d7 pawn but now Magnus just
gets the bushes past a four point so a4
we have King to g7 getting the King away
from the back rank and now a5 you have a
passed pawn so of course you want to
push it we have Knight captures and d5
finally and now Magnus just continues
pushing it a six and it's important to
know that the crossings the bishop on h1
although so far pretty pretty dormant
controls the D queening square so this
will be very important or or maybe it
won't with Knight the c7 and now with a
double attack on the a6 pawn also
guarding the eight square now twice and
here cousin could continue with h7 it's
definitely moving getting the point out
of harm's way but here as the both of
them are very low on the clock
at some point Bobby was had two more
minutes on the clock than Magnus E was
something like four and a half minutes
5e two and a half minutes Magnus but
around here the situation on the clock
pretty much equalized and Magnus played
Knight to c6 and here well it's just a
very unpleasant move to face so what can
you do here now obviously you can
capture the night with the D captures on
c6 there's also the possibility of rook
captures on c6 rook captures and c6
seems to be a sturdier defense for
example rook captures on c6 Bishop
captures on c6 and then now you play
Knight captures an a6 with the idea that
if Queen captures then you can capture
the pawn is no longer pinned and if you
don't if you go back Bishop - G - then
you go night the c5 attack the Queen and
so on and and continue defending but
Fabi
decided plate D captures on c6 now he
allows Queen captures on c7 with check
King to h6 and now a7 so next move
Magnus will capture on c6 again grab
hold of the queening square and push aah
- Queen his pawn rook e8 of course not
allowing this and now Queen to b7 going
after the row can
with Quinta f8 Fabi defends the rook and
now Bishop captures and c6 here just
threatening Queen captures an a8 which
were the winner rook
so Bobby has to give do something he
decides to give up the exchange while
also grabbing the a 7-point so rook
captures on a7 and it's definitely the
best he could hope for from a position
like this as both of them are very very
low on the clock I believe at this point
they are both playing on increment they
have like 5 seconds each so Queen
captures on a 7 rook captures on c6 and
here Queen to d4 by Magnus a nice
centralizing move with the Queen he
wants to play rook to a-1 bringing the
rook over to a7 and try to push his
advantage to a full point we have d5 by
Fabi now defending the bishop the rook
can now move and also is just a very
very solid setup in the center row k1 by
Magnus and now rook to c7 blocking the
a7 square Carlsen still plays if you
don't have you they are like I said
they're both playing on increment and
here Queen to b4 by Fabi so what do you
play here you cannot capture on c7
otherwise you're getting Queen captures
anyone so here we have rook eat a 1 just
bringing it back doubling up on the a
file we have rock out for Sunday 7 Queen
captures on a7 now not allowing rook
captures and a7 and then Queen T 1 check
so Queen captures on a 7 and now Queen
to d2 going after the e3 pawn here
Magnus plays Queen to e7 now with ideas
of Queen to g5 check followed by rook to
a7
probably should lead the checkmate but
Bobby finds a brilliant defensive
resource feel free to pause the video
here and try to find it this brilliant
defensive resource Fabi found with few
seconds on the clock
well I give you a couple of seconds for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations on finding such a
brilliant defensive resource and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show here Bobby played d4 and now the
idea becomes well apparent the idea is
that after Queen g5 check or Quinta for
check once the King retreats and the
rook the a7 check happens the bishop is
now able to block
with bishop to f7 and this is this is
what saves Fabi in this situation so
carlson saw this he played Queen to h4
check King g7 Queen to e7 check King to
h6 and now Queen to g5 with check King
to g7 and it was in this position that
the players agreed to a draw Magnus is
winning in this position but he had
claimed a draw because he was down to
two seconds on the clock he he was in
the moment and couldn't really well
calm down to continue in the game with
only two seconds on the clock so you
don't gain anything by playing rough day
7 check if the rook comes day 7 like I
said you can just block with the bishop
and there is no good way to continue
cannot capture otherwise Queen captures
will pick up the rook because it's
checked the king is on g1 if you push
efore didn't get H sex you push the
Queen back Queen to d8 and then you get
a nice perpetual Queen e1 check here you
can just do you know this for as long as
you want so the way not to go for a
perpetual here is after Queen t7 check
King to h6 you have to put g4 because
you're still up the exchange so it
doesn't matter if black doesn't have any
chairs the only check black and do is
Queen captures on e3 would check and
then after Queen captures pawn captures
now you go after not at the point of why
with attacking the bishop for example
rook a 4 there should be 5 you're gonna
attack the bishop once the bishop moves
back you're gonna attack it once again
and now after the bishop moves first
capture here and then hopefully
recapture this one black will probably
play something like this you will block
the queening square and then after this
G captures an f5 you have this 3 against
2 but it's a rook against the bishop you
should win this however with with so
little time on the clock not so much so
after King to g7 they agree to a draw
and an excellent game by both of them
really that a pawn just marched the
board but Fabi with seconds on the clock
finds the brilliant defensive resource
that is d4 and finds this beautiful
visual retreat with Bishop to f7 so yeah
the the first game of the rapid ends in
a draw I do hope you enjoyed it I would
like to thank georgiana bronzy middle
Mohamed matheus mas one Colonel Nielson
and
Alexandra Kovalenko for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous video Sara thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this very
nice event continuing the coverage of
the European Team Championship and of
course checking up on your wonderful
suggestions so thank you all I will see
soon and they have an excellent rest of
your day and the evening